我不在乎呀，
我是想跟你结婚呀，
我跟你又不是偷我，
又不是小我，
又是不是破坏别人的家庭，
我俩是正经谈恋爱呀，
你现在想甩了我呀，
你才是那个负心汉呀，
你才是那个没人性的东西啊，
我都怀七个月肚子大了，
你居然还让我去打胎，
钱你还不出，
你说这事儿是他怕还是我怕这社会舆论是他担心还是我担心？
我是在一线城市的体制内，
大概年收入20个左右，
父母经济条件一般，
不能支持什么，
但是也对我还挺好的。
他也是跟我一样，
从小县城在一线城市都是体制内，
我们大概认识两年左右吧，
但是他一直跟我说她是一个不婚主义，
觉得他被人素质什么的都平很放心的，
也是接受了这样的一个观点。
3月份左右我意外怀孕了，
他的想法就是可以接受，
但是并不是那种很想要的那个样子，
就是我个人是挺想要的，
呃，
后来就是他也说也可以，
我们会共同抚养，
然后他的爸妈或者是呃，
当时我的爸妈也可以来照顾，
但是从那以后呢，
我们俩之前关系没有那么好，
然后我去做各种检查呀，
产检啊什么的，
他也不会帮忙，
也不会跟嗯请假跟我一块儿去，
基本上都是我一个人做的也。
也有一些矛盾，
是也挺不开心的，
而最近一两个月，
他就是跟我说，
嗯，
还是不想要这个孩子，
还是希望我们打掉以后我们可以比较自由的生活，
我当时也是比较激动，
毕竟也这么久了，
一路也挺顺利和健康的，
嗯，
反正当时也有5个多月了，
但是后来还是不太忍心吧，
就还是留下来，
但是关系就越来越不好，
他是坚持还是不要这个孩子，
就是大家跟我分手这样一个理由，
但我一直觉得他是一个比较稳重，
不会去那种有别的那种意外情况的，
但他跟我说他其实一直都呃有接触别的女生，
然后也有出车过，
但是其实我是没有发现的，
我现在都还没有任何的证据什么的，
都是他跟我说，
然后他还说他以后也可能不会一直跟我在一块儿，
也可能会跟别的女生怎么怎么着，
我已经差不多怀孕七个多月了，
就不知道要不要留着的孩子，
你爸妈是干啥的？
姑娘有点小生意，
但是也没有什么太多的积蓄，
就能帮你带孩子吗？
可以保带孩子，
那你自己是干啥的吗？
我们两都是那种体制类的，
那你今年多大了呢？
我是97年的，
然后他还是94年，
男方收入怎么样来着，
20个，
他跟我这差不多的，
然后我现在可能自己脾蓄大概有20来个吧，
男方就没。
明显他不想结婚，
不想套牢，
那他对这个孩子的态度呢？
其实人家没明说，
人家要明说的话就是他不想要，
但他不明说，
他就是不怎么积极主动的承担责任，
也不花钱，
是目前是这个状态，
对不对，
对，
基本上没让他花钱，
因为我觉得可能现在来说他也花不了什么钱，
一直做的是他肯定会跟我一块儿付，
一样付一样分什么的，
也不会少的，
但是现在因为他不太想要了，
因为他跟我说了好几次，
但是我没有打掉，
所以他现在的意思就是他可能以后也不不会管，
也不会养姑娘啊，
嗯，
因为现在7个多月了，
实话说7个多月都是活的了，
他生下来都是活的了啊，
那咱们呢，
现在转变心态，
转变什么心态呢？
反正我喜欢孩子，
反正我要生孩子，
幸好我给他找了一个有稳定工作的爹，
幸好我要打官司问他要抚养费的话，
能按时按点给我执行到位，
咱这么想问题明白吗？
你现在需要做的是什么呢？
你跟他谈恋爱这个过程当中的聊天记录，
还有就是怀孕啊，
跟她之间的这些聊天记录，
还有你跟他这个过程当中的一些比如说亲密的照片啊，
或者怎么怎么样，
你都作为证据留下来证明这个孩子就是你的是吧？
你不想要这事儿我跟你说，
男人的生育权你想要和不想要取决，
可不是说女人肚子怀上了之后你能决定的了的啊，
所有男人给我听好了你的生育权。
权想要不想要取决于行为的时候，
你要不想要孩子，
要么你就在，
对吧，
要么你就噶，
那个时候的行为就决定着你的生育权，
你那个时候你没在，
你没有噶，
那现在孩子在女性的肚子里了，
男方已经没有决策权了，
男方已经无法决策这个孩子是生还是不生了，
理解吗？
就算他现在明确表示他不要这个孩子，
法律上也站不住脚了，
反正这个小蝌蚪是你的，
DNA是你的，
他行为是你自愿的，
好，
这孩子你就得养，
你得这么考虑问题就是幸好孩子他爸是有正经工作的，
我问他要抚养费一样一个准儿，
我打官司要钱一样一个准儿，
比那些没有正经工作的，
比起那些说还想花我的钱的人，
是不是又强一点儿？
你现在得这么开导自己，
这么想问题，
就觉得我如果是这样子去做的话，
以后我可能自己的就是风平，
别人对我的看法呀，
也会让我过得很不好，
我不在乎呀，
我是想跟你结婚呀，
我跟你又不是偷情，
我又不是小三，
我又是不会破坏别人的家庭，
我俩是正经谈恋爱呀，
你现在想甩了我呀，
你才是那个负心汉呀，
你才是那个没人性的东西呀，
我都怀7个月肚子大了，
你居然还让我去打胎，
钱你还不出，
你说这事儿是他怕还是我怕这社会舆论？
是他担心还是我担心？
我昨天刚给自己塑造成那种被人欺骗，
被人搞大肚子，
被人。
乱中弃，
分分钟把自己塑造成这样的角色，
是他怕还是我怕？
嗯，
他就是说我到时候可能就会变成那种未婚先孕，
然后大家一般都会对女生可能会有到不太有好，
如果我真的要这么做的话，
就会把工作辞掉，
他就可以回受天差，
一个人真的可以突然间变得就特别的面目全非，
但这个事儿还是要尊重你啊，
姑娘啊，
如果你决定好了，
你说你不想跟这个人一辈子有什么的瓜葛，
你现在去做手术，
龙飞姐我也会尊重你的，
因为最近有去医院看过生，
都是说这个月暂如果没有什么健康问题，
接些问题就是正常的医院，
正规的医院都不给做啊，
那我们就要转变思路啊，
姑娘啊，
转变思路，
我不是被迫要生这个孩子的，
我就是想要个孩子，
我就是想要个健康的宝宝啊，
这个男的，
他现在用这种方式，
极端的方式来PUUA我来打压我的话，
正好我问他要钱的时候，
可以把这些当成一个证据，
让那个有权决定他给我多少抚养费的人看到这个人底色的恶劣，
底色的卑鄙，
对他说，
哎呀，
他宁可不要工作了，
也不想给抚养费录音，
他说你赶紧把这孩子打掉吧，
我不想负责任录音，
把这些证据都交给法官了，
他就是，
这两天就是，
他又说他找到了什么关系，
可以就是。
那种可以用那种，
因为现在这个月份不让打，
然后他说可以，
如果他找到了关系，
找到了人，
可以去做这个手术的话，
你先把钱打我卡里，
对我身体造成了损害，
对我精神造成了损害，
对我情感造成的损害，
你先把钱打我卡里，
为什么呢？
一个孩子如果出生了，
你的抚养费要到孩子18岁，
那么这个孩子对你带来的财产损失，
或者说你要支付的代价是多少，
咱不说别的，
一年就说2万块钱的话，
零到18岁一年2万块钱，
差不多快40万了，
对不对，
那现在你想让我把这个孩子打掉，
我不要多，
我最起码8万10万我得要吧，
我的身体上的损害，
我得要这个钱吧，
你把这8万十万你打到我卡里，
我去配合你，
那这样一种行为，
我不知道算是合规合法的吗？
当然合法啦，
我的身体不是因为我一个人会遭受这样的痛苦和损害的，
是因为我们两个人干这个事儿，
我会遭遇这样的痛苦和损害的，
我的身体遭遇的损害是不可逆的，
是不是因为他说如果这样做是要用别人的信息去改掉，
就是因为正常的我这种妊肺的信息是不能够在医院，
那不行的，
那这样的事情会出人命的，
我们对医生是不能隐瞒的，
你是7个月就是7个月，
你不能隐瞒，
医生说我6个月很多数据都不一样了，
很多指数都不一样了，
会要命吧，
姑娘对你的生命负责任，
如果你要。
去做手术的话，
你的年龄，
你的体重，
你怀的月份，
孩子的状况都一定要如实的告知医生，
才能保证你的生命安全，
如果你的年龄，
你的体重，
孩子的月份这些事情对医生有隐瞒的话，
他就是对你的生命有风险，
他的两条路，
要么你钱打我卡里，
我去配合你如实的说我的体重，
我的年龄，
孩子的月份，
要么我就开开心心的，
我就生孩子啊，
这个男生所有的卑鄙的恶劣的聊天记录你都给我留着，
到时候打官司问要抚养费的时候都交给法官，
让法官去判，
就是如果这样子就是人生下来，
我不知道就是不是很确定自己能面对以后的生活，
呃，
预产期其实还有两个月左右，
我就是这2个月的话，
我因为我身体也不太好，
我不是很知道怎么去跟他的工作的地方去沟通，
请假就是一系列的这些问题，
我还没有想好要怎么面对，
就是想问一下有什么建议了，
实话实说，
就说自己身体不太好，
想请假了啊，
你的顶头上司是谁？
实话实说啊，
因为现在法律并没有规定说如果一个女性她没有领结婚证，
她婚前她怀孕了，
她生孩子，
就能成为开除一个女性的理由，
没有法律没有这么规定，
法律虽然说不鼓励女性未婚先孕，
但是对于女性的未婚先孕并没有一个惩罚措施那么作为。
单位的，
他也不该因为这件事情来惩罚你，
是这个意思，
我爸妈吧，
就是他们俩其实关系也不是很好，
然后就前两年他们也有离婚分居，
这样子，
就我跟我爸妈关系也是一直也相处久了也会性格不太合的，
因为如果以后是交，
至少需要我妈妈帮我带，
那我这一点还挺大，
以后可能会处不好，
这样子的，
处不好出现矛盾再说呗，
出现矛盾再说啊，
现在最主要保证什么？
第一你的生命安全，
第二孩子的健康，
最主要保证这两两项，
其他的东西传到桥头，
自然直到时候再说，
好，
嗯，
拜拜，
反正两条路嘛，
就要么就是你钱就到账了，
我去配合你，
要么就是我就生下来，
然后我就要抚养费，
如果说选择第一条路的话，
就一定要保证你的父母要陪着你去保证你的生命安全，
如果要选择第二条路的话，
就是要转化思维，
如论如何是我自己生的，
是我的孩子呀，
反正我问你要钱，
你就得给我呀，
你要转变这个思维，
这日子才能过啊，
我有一种感觉啊，
姐妹们啊，
我到底要怎么做，
我才能更出名呢？
我才能让所有的女性都认识我呢？
如果所有的女性都认识我的话，
是不是会就少很多悲剧，
少很多这种什么未婚先孕的，
什么人家都明摆着不不婚，
不想结婚，
其实明摆着就是没看上咱的，
咱就别往。
贴了咱就别承担这样的风险了，
记得点赞关注哦。